you just slide into everybody's reply
you start doing funny stuff obviously i
see it you're trolling me or you're you
know mixing it up with somebody else and
it's like okay of course i'm gonna
respond you're talking about me i have
no choice
i'm at least gonna like it i have a
sense of humor but you must have gotten
blocked did you go over the line with
some of these memes did you you know
piss people off because when you're
doing comedy it's a fine line you know
like the joke and the hurt could be
right next to each other
yeah there's definitely
it's it's funny enough it's a lot of
public market hedge fund anonymous
twitter accounts that don't like it
you probably know the exact archetype
i'm talking about yeah it's just
probably not the funnest people to hang
around anyways
i think most vcs they kind of like we
all kind of acknowledge like yeah we are
kind of a meme like we are kind of
pretty easy to make fun of and i think
it's pretty easy to make fun of yeah
it's like who are these affluent ebags
who just write checks and then take
credit for all their portfolio companies
success and yes what is that job even
doing like you listen to a pitch and you
say yes it's like okay you wrote a check
yeah like congratulations you're an atm
i always tell people like don't forget
you're an atm like people are not
talking to you because your personality
they want a chat they want money to
fulfill their dreams
and sometimes maybe on the margins you
can help them with some stuff
um but you didn't
you didn't uh go fly so close to the sun
that you burned any relationships that
you can think of who has like the least
sense of humor who's got the least sense
of humor that like was like blocked you
or something certainly mark andreessen's
blocked you for sure oh he actually
hasn't he's created a couple of minutes
to do
yeah he uh
yeah i love a16z they're awesome i think
they're the strategy that they're trying
to execute on like there's all these
different if you think about venture
firms and you pick a strategy it's just
like companies like the one that they're
executing on
it's working like i think they're really
good at what they do and there's other
lanes to compete on and so yeah i have a
ton of respect for them i think they've
done a really good job so tell me about
mechanically uh you know for the benefit
obviously i know of various funds but
for the benefit of the audience there's
people who are watching who are 22 years
old or they're 19 year old turner
novak's in college watching this and
like okay yeah he did it at 29 30 i'd
like to do it at 24 25
how does it work
to you know raise the micro fund this
like 10 million dollar my first fun kind
of situation my first one was 10 million
in fact as well uh yeah i just passed
the hat
you know 10 years ago at a poker table
with a bunch of my besties you know
that's how i did it you know didn't do
twitter but your technique over twitter
seems a lot more efficient yeah honestly
it was so
initially like it was a pipe dream
thought it might take a really long time
it was just trying to build a track
record and like trust because people are
not
there's people who want you to be a
fiduciary of their capital and get a
return
and there's other people if you're a vc
it's and if you're raising a small fund
they want you for deal flow like it's
almost like be a scale for me 50k
tell me when your best portfolio company
is raising a series a or a series b i
want to lead the round with a 20 million
dollar check so those are kind of the
spectrum of the people it's like that's
a new dynamic in the industry which is
mark andreessen did that in my first
fund a bunch of venture firms who were
in my first fund do you have sequoia
capital in yours i was the first outside
venture fund that sequoia backed
actually would launch back in my first
one um and that's a new phenomenon mark
andreessen did this as a way to sort of
spread influence he put 50k into a bunch
of funds i subsequently kicked him out
of my second fund well he wouldn't speak
he wouldn't come on the podcast
and he wouldn't come to the event so
like do a fireside chat and i was like
he's like do i have in order for us to
like be in business together do i have
to like be on your podcast or come to an
event i said yes
and he said okay and i said great
just that was the end of the
relationship basically well i started
like a jerk move like you you want to
support me or you don't want to support
me you know like pick one mark like and
then you block me and unblock me and
email me and then not email me and then
you know
want to buy my super human chairs for me
and you know i was just like no i'm not
telling you my superhuman shares like
but this is a new phenomenon
of venture firms wanting to use you as
an early signal so how many venture
firms are in or partners in venture
firms are in your fund
approximately a dozen it's a pretty big
number uh venture firms and partners
probably like 50
50 or so wow they put in 100k each 35
million so on average they hit 100 or 50
it's 2.5 to 5 million something like
that
yeah it was probably about 75 75 average
yeah that makes sense so that's amazing
now you have 50 of them you have a
portfolio company that's breaking out
how do you communicate that to 50 people
because they all want to relieve the a
so you just do a bcc
or did they just read your
lp update like hey here's what we
invested and then they just look at the
spreadsheet or do you give them a
spreadsheet and say hey here's what
we're investing in so they can double
click on it and it's up to them to go
drill down and ask for the the
introduction
yeah i think that's the art of it right
like you want to keep all these kind of
downstream or upstream i guess depending
on how you think about investors
downstream is the way to happen i think
of it yeah yeah
the way i think of the downstream thing
just for people to understand the
metaphor what we're talking about here
is downstream investors
so if turner and i are at the well yc's
at the well
you know you're just watching you know
the water come out of the well uh you
know the spring it goes downstream and
then seed funds that do three or four
million dollar checks and venture funds
that do 10 20 million dollar checks
would be downstream from us downstream
from the series a funds would of course
be the late stage ones
yep yeah so it's essentially you
yeah you just try to have a good
relationship with all of them and you
kind of know what people like like some
people i i invest in kind of tilts
consumer there's a little bit of more
like software stuff and i just kind of
know this guy's not going to like this
thing
don't have to mention it to him um but
you just kind of balance it and you i
think ultimately you take what the
founder wants ahead of everything sure
like you might say
you know hey just a heads up these guys
are raising money he no he's not taking
you intros but you can reach out if you
want and i'll just tell the founders
like hey i mentioned to some people
these guys might reach out you don't
have to reply but
you know you probably should with these
guys you know so it's a spectrum you
just try to balance it it's like a
relationship thing you're essentially
into the uh how far into the 10 million
deployment are you
so of the fund we have invested it's
probably like 55 60 percent
um and through spv is kind of total
uh it's like 25 million oh so you're
doing the fun
model which is the model i i did or
pioneered yeah and it was explained to
the audience how that works
yeah so the so the the fund is
essentially 25k to 300k checks try to
have a balanced portfolio
i basically pitched people there's going
to be 40 to 50 companies nothing is
going to be tilted and weighted really
heavily in the fund and there are some
cases where we'll put a million dollars
1.2 million in the seed or 5 million and
a b or 10 million in a series d and i
can't fit in the fund so
we'll have invested in those companies
earlier in the fund but then when they
follow on and break out we'll go to all
the lps and there's some people who
don't they don't want to do sbvs they
you know they're like i don't want to
pay fees like i want to invest director
i just i want to leave the round but
there's a lot of people they're just
like high net worth you know have a lot
of money that are like hey let me know i
can't do 100k checks but let me know
when we can do a million or 5 million in
spv and we're interested and
um so you kind of use those to augment
the fund um i actually do not like the
spv process
it is i think it's a hassle we're
raising the money um it's it's just like
it takes a lot of for you have to
convince people this week
you have to pass the hat you have to
write a deal memo
which you're doing diligence like
who does diligence
uh
i do massively uh
i do absurd diligence for the same fund
yeah i don't i don't sleep usually i
just you know we just do diligence all
night
all around the world tech companies are
innovating and driving returns for
investors while our crowd analyzes many
of these companies they search across
the global private market then they
select the ones with the greatest growth
potential and finally they bring them to
you and me from personalized medicine to
cyber security to robotics to quantum
computing and much much more whether
it's in a state-of-the-art lab a startup
garage or anywhere in between our crowd
identifies innovators so you can invest
when growth potential is greatest and
that's early don't i know it our crowds
accredited investors have already
invested over one billion dollars in
growing tech companies and many of their
members have benefited from 46 ipos or
exits now you can truly diversify your
portfolio by investing early in
innovative private market companies that
are proud join the fastest growing
venture capital investment community in
the world at ourcrowd.com slash twist
that's r crowd o-u-r-c-r-o-w-d
dot com slash twist to sign up for free
today and start reading all those great
deal memos